Jay-Z watching Rihanna at halftime Jay-Z
brings a special plus one to the Super
Bowl and no it wasn't Beyonce on Sunday
the music mogul attended the big game at
State Farm stadium in Arizona with his
11 year old daughter Blue Ivy the
daddy-daughter Duo was spotted ahead of
kickoff sporting matching all black
outfits that's Jay rocking a what else
Rock Nation Super Bowl sweatshirt white
sneakers and sunglasses while blue looks
Chic in a Tupac graphic tee black hat
gold necklace Shades and red and white
sneakers we support each other that's
what we do that's when Jay went into
full-blown Instagram dad mode squatting
down to get just the right angle of blue
jumping in the end zone
[Music]
of course Jay-Z was at the big game to
support Rihanna during her highly
anticipated Apple music halftime show
[Applause]
foreign
company Roc Nation produces the halftime
show and REE is signed to Jay's record
label of the same name the Super Bowl is
one of the biggest stages in the world
in fact the two have collabed on several
hits together over the years like Run
This Town
[Music]
[Applause]
some fans even expected Jay to join Riri
on stage during the Big Show but on
Sunday night it was all about Rihanna
and another surprise guest
Riri dropped the big news that she and
ASAP Rocky are expecting their second
child together by revealing her baby
bump on live TV I'm still pinching
myself really I'm grateful I'm grateful
Rihanna both listen she's an incredible
individual
that's all I can say she's a one of one
I that the Rihanna performance was
perfect meanwhile her man was spotted in
the crowd proudly cheering on his
Leading Lady while she performed all of
her biggest hits
ahead of the show A source told E.T
Rocky and their son whom he and REE
welcomed last May plan to be by
Rihanna's side and another source says
Rihanna adores being a mom and it's her
biggest accomplishment which Echoes what
she and Rocky have told E.T what are you
looking forward to As you move into a
new chapter of your life ASAP I'm just
excited for what I don't know yet you
know everything is new to me so you know
I'm excited what is the best part about
motherhood right now Rihanna oh my God
the mornings just like seeing his
morning face yeah and you know like
seeing a baby with like little bags and
waking up and they're just like startled
they're trying to figure out where they
at is the cutest it's my favorite part
of the day from Jay-Z and Blue Ivy to
Rihanna and baby number two safe to say
the Super Bowl was jam-packed with cute
kiddo moments
[Music]